thanks for having me hi pal how are you
I'm doing great we watching back there I
love the life and going on you are alive
your haired kind of be sticking out yeah
welcome to the show
Thanks good to have you here to be here
lots to talk about yes would you be my
friend in real life is that something
that's even if I've heard you saying
that yeah don't you guys feel as you get
older you it's like I can remember the
same thing kind of happened to my dad it
seemed like I was like does my dad have
fewer and fewer friends as he gets older
yeah it's like the mob you know the way
they shut the books I'm like I'm feel
like I'm old I don't really need any new
friends I don't mean you guys cuz I
could always use some business
connection how was that I think it would
be such a low impact friend you and I
I've seen you with that sushi restaurant
you and I we get sushi together we both
liked music we talked about music I
would be such a good friend for you to
blow me off like that if we do this what
I'd like to do we're not gonna have to
just
I mean if it what kind of friendship
business one minute you want to be
friends in the next minute I don't know
what we say it's all closed up that they
might work up to that but what I'm
saying is this would be this would be
low-impact relationship people yeah but
I would like to leave all my old friends
behind if we start being just start new
just start new so let's start fresh yeah
I don't have that many friends so I'll
jettison the two I have you jettison
here and then we'll just start out we'll
be like wingman buddy around together is
that what they say these days I have no
idea I'm not very good I'm not right for
15 years I have no idea how any of this
works anymore up to down with the lingo
you